en plena noche y sin prensa el
presidente colombiano iván duque viajó a
la ciudad de cali para reunirse con las
autoridades locales tras los
enfrentamientos entre civiles armados y
organizaciones indígenas del domingo la
presión política sobre el mandatario
creció para que se desplazara el
epicentro de las protestas tenemos claro
que hay que priorizar una serie de
intervenciones que son necesarias para
generar una vocación de esperanza y de
futuro para nuestra juventud
varios civiles armados y con camionetas
de alta gama dispararon con armas de
fuego contra organizaciones indígenas
que apoyan el paro en colombia unas
imágenes que inundaron las redes
sociales y despertaron las denuncias
contra la policía por supuestamente
proteger a los civiles
un archivo con personal de guardia que
acudió a mediar ante la situación de
tensión y del rescate del consejero
mayor de las internas heart on se puede
quien se encontraba hostigado por
sujetos desconocidos que se movilizaban
en tres vehículos blindados de color
blanco sin placas en la ruta del sector
de pance fueron atacados con armas de
fuego por hombres que estaban de civil
resguardados por la policía nacional
según el consejo indígena hay 12
comuneros heridos cuatro de ellos de
gravedad- aunque el gobierno mantiene la
cifra en ocho vecinos de la zona
afectada de barrios adinerados en el sur
de cali denuncian que los bloqueos del
paro los tienen secuestrados y la
policía colombiana acusa a los indígenas
de estar saqueando casas y apartamentos
unas denuncias que los indígenas niegan
el partido de gobierno el centro
democrático hizo un llamado para una
acción militar contundente y sostenida
en la ciudad
duke ya anunció un mayor despliegue de
la fuerza pública
cali despertó con el patrullaje de unos
12.000 miembros de la fuerza pública
entre policías y militares el presidente
pidió a los indígenas que volvieran a
sus territorios y exigió el fin de los
bloqueos organizaciones internacionales
hicieron sonar las alarmas por los
incidentes la oficina de derechos
humanos de la onu condenó los ataques